how do I know if I have the stomach flu  or a hangover well honey did you drink  last night glug glug did you have food  or did you have alcohol the internet is  not for stupidity ma'am the internet is  for smart established doctors like me  and my friend Louis here I think  tweet okay another question okay Kelly  underscore Sheridan won finally a great  question how much Vitamin C is too much  yes sometimes too much vitamins is too  much you always get these things on  medical shows going like should I take  this supplement should I take this  supplement and honestly you can get  hyper vitaminosis like if you go to GNC  or some other stories they'll say like  oh this you get like two thousand  percent of the recommended daily  allowance of vitamin you know C you can  actually get side effects and symptoms  or GI symptoms from too much vitamins so  it's probably good just to get like a  hundred percent of the recommended daily  allowance that's really all you need  great question